Imagine you're standing on a crowded city bus, the doors have just closed, the engine
groans, and suddenly your heart starts pounding against your ribs, your palms are sweating,
you feel this wave of absolute suffocating terror.
Oh, that's a nightmare scenario.
Right.
Now, most people watching you grip the handrail with white knuckles would guess they'd think
you have social anxiety.
But what if the reason you're panicking has absolutely nothing to do with the people
around you?
What's the anxiety you're feeling is something structurally, fundamentally different.
I mean, it's a completely different mechanism at play.
But from the outside, the behavior, you know, the panic, the avoidance, it looks identical.
Totally identical.
Right.
And that visual overlap is exactly where so many of us, including professionals, misread
what is actually happening in the brain.
Okay, let's unpack this because today we're cracking open the secret language that clinicians
use to decode human behavior.
I love that.
It's a secret language.
It really is.
We got our hands on some incredibly detailed prep course notes for this deep dive.
They're from an instructor named Keek over at Pass Ready Prep.
And these notes are meant for people taking clinical licensing exams, focusing on the
smaller sort of glossed over categories of the anxiety family, the diagnostic F codes.
Which I love framing as a secret language, honestly, because when people say, you know,
I'm anxious, it's this giant gray catch all umbrella.
Oh, absolutely.
But in the clinical manual, anxiety isn't just one flavor.
It's highly specific.
And these particular codes, these smaller categories, they're precisely the areas where the most
massive diagnostic blind spots occur.
Well let's start right in the F40.2 range, specific phobia.
The notes define this as a marked out of proportion fear of one particular object or
situation.
So like heights, needles, dogs, flying.
Yeah.
But the threshold here isn't just, I really hate spiders, right?
Far from it.
If you've actually hit the F40.2 criteria, this fear has to last at least six months
and it has to involve active life altering avoidance.
Life altering?
Yes.
We are talking about someone who will take a three day train ride across the country
just to avoid a two hour flight, even if it means losing a promotion at work or someone
who hasn't gone into their own basement in eight months because they saw a spider down
there once.
The avoidance literally dictates the architecture of their daily life.
Which brings us to the first massive misconception or I guess clinical pitfall in the source
material.
It's about how you treat that level of avoidance.
Because if someone is ruining their career to avoid a plane, the instinct is get this
person a prescription fast.
Which is completely wrong.
Wait, really?
Totally wrong.
The absolute gold standard, the first line treatment for a specific phobia is exposure
therapy, not medication.
If you're looking at a treatment plan for F40.2 and it leads with prescribing a pill, it's
a major misstep.
I want to understand the mechanics of why that is.
Why does a pill fail here?
Because a specific phobia isn't a generalized chemical imbalance that you can just dial
down with a sedative.
It is a highly localized learned association.
The brain's amygdala has incorrectly tagged one specific input, say an airplane, as a
legal existential threat.
Right.
So a pill might make you drowsy or maybe chemically numb your nervous system
temporarily, but it doesn't untag the threat.
The moment the medication wears off, the brain still believes airplanes equal death.
So it's almost like a, wait, let me try this.
It's like a home security system that works perfectly 99% of the time.
Okay, I'm with you.
But the owner accidentally programmed it to trigger the most massive ear splitting police
dispatching alarm only when the neighbor's golden retriever walks by.
Yes.
When you unplug the alarm speaker, you have to actually reprogram the sensor.
That is a great way to look at it.
And the reprogramming is exposure therapy.
The only way to rewire that specific neural pathway is habituation.
So you have to trigger the alarm system on purpose.
Exactly.
You have the person look at a picture of a dog, then a video.
Then they stand 20 feet from a dog.
They sit with the noise of that alarm, feeling the panic, until the brain's fear
center eventually realizes, oh, the house didn't burn down.
We survived.
You proved the threat is false through lived experience.
You let the dog walk past the sensor until the system stops caring?
That makes total mechanical sense.
Yeah, it really does.
But what happens when that security sensor isn't triggered by a specific object,
like a dog or a plane, but by the physical environment itself?
Like what if the terror is about the feeling that you absolutely cannot escape the room?
Then we leave F40.2 and enter agoraphobia, which is coded as F40.00.
The defining feature shifts here.
It is the fear of two or more situations where escape might be difficult or where help might
be unavailable if you start to panic.
And the source notes list things like public transit, open parking lots, enclosed spaces
like movie theaters, standing in crowds or lines, or just being outside of the home alone.
Notice how broad that is compared to a specific phobia.
Yeah, it's everywhere.
Because the anxiety is bleeding into multiple environments, the treatment approach has to
shift.
Exposure therapy is still a core component, usually wrapped into cognitive behavioral therapy
or CBT.
Right.
But here, it is frequently paired with an SSRI medication.
Wait, let me pause you there.
We throw around the term SSRI a lot, selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor.
Right.
But for those of us who aren't writing prescriptions, what exactly is that doing in the brain
to help the CBT work better?
Like, why is a pill okay here, but not for the specific phobia?
It's a great distinction.
Serotonin is a neurotransmitter that helps regulate mood and anxiety.
An SSRI blocks the brain from reabsorbing serotonin too quickly.
So it leaves more of an active in the gap between your neurons.
Precisely.
For someone with agoraphobia, their baseline level of panic is often simmering so high
across so many different daily environments that they are too overwhelmed to even attempt
therapy.
So the SSRI acts as a chemical buffer.
It lowers the floor of that ambient panic just enough so the patient can actually engage
with the CBT and do the hard work of exposure.
Okay, that clarifies the treatment.
But going back to the diagnosis, let's return to that crowded city bus scenario we started
with because Keek's notes highlight a massive blind spot here.
Yeah, they do.
From the outside, agoraphobia looks identical to social anxiety.
What's fascinating here is that this is the most common mix-up in the book.
If you see someone refusing to go to a concert or sweating on a crowded bus, the default assumption
is usually social anxiety.
Because there are people around.
Right.
But the internal mechanism, the actual why, is completely different.
Social anxiety is fundamentally about scrutiny.
It is the deep fear of being judged, humiliated, or negatively evaluated by others.
Agoraphobia, on the other hand, is strictly about being trapped or stranded without help.
So it's escape versus scrutiny.
Precisely.
If we break down the mechanics of the therapy, how does that shift the actual work you do
with a patient?
Like, if I'm terrified of the bus and you misdiagnose me with social anxiety, what happens?
We waste months of time.
Yeah, because if I think you have social anxiety, my CBT work with you is going to
focus on cognitive restructuring around judgment.
I'll ask you, what's the worst that happens if someone sees you sweating?
Are they really staring at your shoes?
You're reality testing the social evaluation.
Exactly.
But if you actually have F40000 agoraphobia, you don't care if people are staring at
your shoes.
You are terrified that the bus doors are going to jam, you're going to have a heart
attack, and the paramedics won't be able to reach you.
Oh, wow.
So talking about self-esteem is useless.
Completely useless.
Agoraphobia, the therapy has to focus on inter-receptive exposure.
Which is what?
Exactly.
Getting you comfortable with the physical sensation of a racing heart, building your
confidence that you can survive a panic symptom without needing an immediate escape
hatch.
You really have to know what's actually broken before you try to fix it.
So we've established that agoraphobia is essentially a terror of being detached from
a safe escape route or access to medical help.
But what if that vital sense of safety isn't tied to a door or a hospital or a
location at all?
What if your entire sense of safety is tethered to a person?
That transitions us perfectly to the third clinical category in the notes.
Separation anxiety disorder, F93.0.
Okay.
This is defined as a developmentally inappropriate excessive fear about being
separated from specific attached figures.
The clinical manifestations are intense, immense distress at separation, persistent
nightmares about losing the person, constant worry that they will come to harm.
And a total refusal to sleep away from them, right?
Exactly.
And the standard treatment is CBT, often family-based, because the anxiety is so
intertwined with the family dynamic.
But here's where it gets really interesting.
There is a massive diagnostic update here that blows up a lot of assumptions.
Huge update.
Separation anxiety disorder is no longer just a childhood diagnosis.
The manual explicitly recognizes it in fully grown adults.
Which represents a monumental paradigm shift in psychology.
Historically, the field viewed this purely as a pediatric issue.
Like you just outgrow it.
Right.
If a 30-year-old had extreme anxiety about being away from their spouse, they were slapped
with a label of codependency or borderline personality traits or simply generalized anxiety.
But we now recognize that the exact same neurological mechanisms of separation terror
can exist in an adult.
Hold on.
I'm struggling with this one a bit.
I need to push back.
When I hear separation anxiety, I picture a toddler screaming at daycare, you know, wrapping
themselves around their dad's leg.
But an adult, if a 40-year-old is tracking their spouse's phone 10 times a day or refusing
to let them travel for work without melting down, how is that not just toxic control
or extreme jealousy?
It's a fair question.
Where is the line between an F93.0 panic disorder and just being a terribly controlling
learner?
It all comes down to the core motivation, the internal narrative.
Someone with severe jealousy or control issues is tracking the phone because they suspect
infidelity or because they demand dominance over their partner's time.
They're angry or suspicious.
An adult with separation anxiety disorder is tracking the phone out of paralyzing catastrophic
dread.
They aren't checking to see if their spouse is at a bar with someone else.
They're checking to ensure their spouse isn't dead in a ditch.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
That is a radically different internal experience.
It's pure terror.
It's the adult who physically cannot sleep a single wink if their partner is out of town
because their brain safety mechanism is entirely outsourced to the presence of that specific
human being.
So when that person leaves, their nervous system registers it as an existential threat.
If we brush that off as just being a little clingy or we judge them as toxic and controlling,
we deny them the specific interventions that can actually help.
How do you even begin to treat that in an adult?
You can't exactly do pediatric family therapy.
No.
You use CBT to help them build internal safety.
You work with them and often the spouse to slowly habituate to distance.
Like exposure therapy again.
Exactly.
Maybe the spouse goes to the grocery store for 20 minutes and the patient practices
sitting with the discomfort without texting them.
You challenge the catastrophic thoughts.
Just because they haven't replied in 10 minutes doesn't mean they're in a car crash.
You rebuild their tolerance for independence.
That forces such a profound reevaluation of adult relationships.
We are so quick to judge behavior on the surface without asking what the underlying architecture
of that fear actually is.
We really are.
Which really sets the stage for the final category in Keek's Prep Notes.
We've talked about the panic of being separated from a safe person.
Now let's look at how anxiety can completely alter our physical ability to interact when
we are thrust into expected social situations without that safety net.
We are talking about selective mutism, code F94.0A.
The diagnostic criteria require consistent failure to speak in specific social situations
where speaking is expected despite speaking comfortably in other situations.
The classic hallmark being the child who is a total chatterbox at home but absolutely
silent at school.
And the notes specify a chronological rule here.
This silence must persist for at least a month and it cannot be limited to the very first
month of school.
The timeline is so important because a lot of children experience transient shyness or
adjustment periods when starting a new school year.
The F94.0 diagnosis applies when the adjustment period ends but the silence becomes entrenched.
Yeah, how is it treated?
The treatment involves specialized behavioral interventions, sometimes combined with an SSRI,
to lower that baseline anxiety threshold we talked about earlier.
But the clinical pitfall here feels like the most tragic one we've covered.
The Golden Rule Kayak puts in the notes is, treat the anxiety, not the refusal.
Because of the impulse for every adult who encounters this is to assume the kid is just
being stubborn.
The assumption of defiance is the biggest hurdle.
Adults look at a child who won't answer a simple question and they feel challenged.
They assume it is a behavioral issue, you know, a power struggle.
Or alternatively, they assume the child has a profound language or speech delay.
But the reality of selective mutism is that it is not a language disorder and it is certainly
not defiance.
The child has the vocabulary.
They have the physical ability to speak.
The silence is an involuntary symptom of profound anxiety.
It's not like, well, let's use an analogy.
It's not a broken speaker system, right?
The hardware works.
The wires are connected and it's not someone stubbornly crossing their arms and refusing
to press the play button.
It's more like the volume knob is jammed.
No, wait, that doesn't capture the involuntary part?
Let's tweak it.
It's more like the entire electrical circuit powering the volume knob has been tripped by
a massive power surge.
Yes, a short circuit.
So what does this all mean?
Biologically what we're looking at is the freeze response.
We all know fight or flight, but freeze is the third option.
The anxiety in that specific environment, the classroom, the playground, triggers such a massive
threat response in the nervous system that the vocal cords literally paralyze.
That is heartbreaking.
It is.
The child might desperately want to answer the teacher, but the physical mechanism of speech
has been hijacked by their brain's survival instinct.
So what does a teacher or a parent do with that information?
How do they reframe their approach when they are staring at a kid who won't say hello?
It demands a complete shift from frustration to empathy.
When you think a child is defying you, your instinct is to bribe them, threaten them,
or punish them.
If you don't answer me, you're losing recess.
This just makes the anxiety worse.
Exactly.
If you understand the F-94.0 mechanism, you realize that punishing a child with selective
mutism is like punishing a child for shivering in a blizzard.
Wow, you're punishing an autonomic nervous system response.
Exactly.
So you stop demanding speech, you remove the pressure, you focus entirely on making
the environment feel safe enough that their nervous system can slowly unfreeze, you
allow nonverbal communication, you use small, low-pressure interactions, and you treat the
underlying terror, not the silence.
Treat the anxiety, not the refusal.
That is powerful.
If we pull all the way back, looking at these four F-codes, Keek's notes really give us
a masterclass in reading beneath the surface of human behavior.
Let's do a quick synthesis of these mechanics.
If we connect this to the bigger picture, the three line is that misidentifying the
root cause guarantees the wrong treatment.
For specific phobia, F40.2, the pitfall is seeking a chemical fix for a localized, learned
fear.
The brain needs exposure, not a sedative.
The neighbor's dog and the security alarm?
Exactly.
For agoraphobia, F40.00, the blind spot is confusing it with social anxiety.
The intervention fails if you treat a fear of scrutiny when the patient is actually
terrified of being trapped without help.
The crowded bus test, escape versus judgment.
Spot on.
For separation anxiety, F93.0, the trap is assuming it expires in childhood.
Adults can experience the exact same catastrophic dread when separated from an attached figure
and it requires targeted CVT, not electro-intoxic jealousy.
And finally, selective mutism, F94.0, the tragedy of misreading an anxiety-freeze response
as deliberate defiance.
You've got it.
Understanding the secret language, these underlying mechanics, it matters so much
to you listening right now, even if you never take a clinical licensing exam in your
life.
Absolutely.
Because tomorrow, you might see a kid at a family barbecue who won't speak to anyone,
and instead of calling them rude, you'll recognize the short circuit.
Or you might have a friend who constantly bails on plans to go to the mall, and you'll
realize they aren't afraid of people looking at them, they're afraid of the space itself.
Yeah.
When we understand the specific architecture of anxiety, we stop judging the surface
behavior and we start seeing the invisible internal battles people are fighting.
It replaces judgment with genuine curiosity and comprehension.
And once you learn to see these structural differences, you start noticing them everywhere.
It fundamentally changes the lens.
Yeah.
But as we wrap up this deep dive, I want to leave you with one final thought to mull
over.
We've just spent, what, 20 minutes of dissecting how profoundly our behaviors are
panic and even our physical ability to speak are tied to our surroundings.
We have.
If a fear of crowds or the ability to use your vocal cords or a sense of catastrophic
dread can be so heavily dependent on the specific room you are in, or the presence
of one specific safe person, it raises a fascinating question.
How much of what we consider our fixed, unchangeable personality is actually just a
continuous ongoing reaction to the specific spaces and people we surround ourselves with
every day?
If you completely change the room, do you change the person?
Something to explore on your own.
Until next time.